a very exciting time for las vegas we've
watched resorts world come together on
the outside and now today we're getting
our first look inside
the newest property on the strip good
afternoon thanks so much for joining us
at four i'm kirsten joyce and i'm
christian casadas world resorts world
finally opening
tomorrow night bianca holman takes us
for a tour
the north end of the las vegas strip has
a new attraction
construction for resorts world started
in may 2015
and it now finally comes to an end it's
been a long time in the works here
it's been a tough year on everybody and
we're really excited that things are
getting better and we're excited about
tomorrow night
resorts world is where the former
stardust once stood as the world's
largest hotel in 1958 this new property
has
more than three thousand rooms and
suites it's actually
three brands in one hilton conrad and
crockford
gary steffen from hilton brands says
there's something for everyone
every one of the hotels will have its
own independent identity
which is really critical when you're
putting a collection brand together
because you don't want to
standardize those every one of them
should have its own identity
but you know you're booking that ultra
luxury experience
and it's going to be brought to life in
a very las vegas
resorts world way every square foot is
unique
from the casino floor to the sports book
inside a saloon
there's cashless gambling and with the
touch of a phone you can have grubhub
deliver a bite from one of the 40
food and beverage options on the
property the senior vp of operations
says they plan to deliver
what guests want as we come out of this
pandemic i think there's two things that
everybody will want to do number one
they will want to go and see families
and number two they will want to attend
live events we're talking about an
unprecedented lineup of headlining
residencies
celine dion carrie underwood katy perry
and luke bryan all have ink deals to
play the ultra high tech 5000 seat
theater
the day and night clubs will be busy as
well with big time djs such as tiesto
zed dj snake and others resorts world
will be the best in class
of everything and for this opening
weekend the resort has enlisted the
likes of paris hilton
and darius rucker to help open and
welcome guests and for fourth of july
miley cyrus bianca holman 8 news now
you can book a room at resorts world
like bianca mentioned the three
different hotel towers
each offer something different as we
mentioned there are luxurious villas
and palaces at crockford the conrad has
its own private reception lobby and vip
check-in
and the hilton features its classic stay
i think that you're going to
see that where people are going to stay
maybe at the hilton the first time and
then they're going to say wow
let's experience the conrad and that's
how we look at it when we combine the
brands
in in such a impressive resort like this
rates this weekend range between 460 and
560 dollars a night
tomorrow's grand opening includes some
private events followed by public
ceremonies but we're told that the
public can officially step inside at
about 11 p.m